hi it's so good to see you and your your
beautiful skin
i see you're still on the skincare
routine how are you feeling
i feel
really good as soon as the episode aired
i felt a weight lifted off my shoulders
you know like the past year has just
been like family and friends like did
you win like you could tell me if you
want i'm just like guys this is a five
million dollar like penalty i'm not
going to tell you if i won but like now
i can enjoy the rest of the season and
still feel really proud of the game that
i played because i i left
feeling really good and to this day i
feel very proud of myself
well i feel like your exit really stood
out because it looked like you took that
blind side really well so what were you
thinking when jeff read the votes
you know
when people have like near death
experiences and they talk about like
seeing the white light and like their
life flashing before their eyes it was
very accurate as you're getting
blindsided right as my name kept coming
up every conversation that i had that
afternoon was like rushing back to me
but in like a different context and
people's answers at tribal all of a
sudden the subtext changed right like
when
lindsay said tonight's theme is about
evening the playing field i thought she
was home about getting rid of jonathan
so that we could all like have a shot at
like immunity but she was talking about
getting rid of me
like as the strategic threat so that
they would have a better opportunity and
i was just astonished at the level of
gameplay this season so when i got
blindsided i felt a lot of pride not
just for myself but for like my
castmates who were who are here to play
on season 42 you know
was there anything as you reflect back
on all those conversations at camp when
you look back and you think
that was the tell that was the hint that
it was me
there were a lot of tells in hindsight
i would say the biggest one and it's
like part of my strategy that didn't
make the air because i didn't win it
doesn't matter was
my fake amulet idol which was a strategy
that i use to like placate people not
into not playing their shot in the dark
so what it was was i had my amulet key
and i had mike's immunity scroll because
when we aligned on like night seven i
told him about the amulet and the next
day i was like can i use your scroll
because i want to trick daniel into
thinking that i have an idol because at
that point daniel still thought i was
working with him and i told him i was
like listen i found this idol right
because there's it's survivor there's
lots of idols and i would be willing to
play it for you my ally if you gave me
the word at tribal but i need you in
return to vote the way that i ask you to
so that
you know everything goes according to
plan and as a result he didn't take a
shot in the dark and i did the same
thing with chanel at merge you know
whether or not they believed it
you know irrelevant at this point but
um that afternoon mike asked me for the
scroll back after like 12 days so that
should have been my first red flag was
like why do you need your immunity
scroll back all of a sudden but yeah
also don't leave your shoes at camp if
you leave your shoes at camp you will
get blindsided that night
i want to ask about mike because it
looked like you guys had a good thing
going on but then he ended up deciding
to turn on you so did you anticipate
that he was going to turn on you and
what was your relationship with him like
i was really close with mike you know
even before the jenny vote we were very
close we bonded over a lot of things
like we both come from very similar
backgrounds we get we grew up in like
poor communities um and we bonded on a
personal level so i always had a very
like a lot of empathy for mike and i
think he had a lot for me too
and
even though we were very linked
personally i think strategically we were
never
super aligned on like how to like
approach the game like for instance he
wanted to work with the men and like he
preferred braun and also he would like
bring me into alliances without really
like consulting me first and i would
find out after the fact and then i would
have to re-navigate so um mike and i had
a very interesting dynamic and
um
watching
mike
bite omer's lie
for me was very interesting because as
impressive as it was for omer i was so
embarrassed for mike because
mike you've lived with me for 19 days
you know i don't talk like that i would
never go around saying mike i control
his vote he's my puppet who talks like
that you know so like it was very easy
to sit back and say he should have
corroborated with me but also at that
point i think
mike was maybe a little scared of me i
think a lot of people were they saw how
aggressive i played i was very visibly
like strategic and i think a lot of
people maybe like were afraid to talk to
me and you know yeah
well so on that point in this episode it
looked like it was a toss-up between you
and jonathan who was going to go home so
do you think that like i want to know
why weren't people considering voting
out jonathan at that point because he
looks like a powerhouse in challenges
yeah right i think it's such a catch-22
like you want to vote out the biggest
physical threat so you have a better
chance of getting to the end but when
the biggest fiscal threat is jonathan
and
he's not very eloquent and he doesn't
really have great strategy it's like do
you keep him or do you keep high who
literally
everyone wants to get out because it
benefits their game because he's viewed
as a strategic threat i think the answer
is like a little obvious and i can't
even fault them for that because if i
was given the opportunity to take out
jonathan or omar with what i know now i
would 100 choose omer because at least
with jonathan and i think the editors
really highlighted this at tribal like
he couldn't answer a question to save
his life whereas i could
talk my way you know into and out of
anything and that was really the
distinction between do we keep jonathan
or hi
well so something that i wish that we
saw more of was the relationship you had
with the other amulet holders because it
looked like an episode one this could
lead to something and i was curious to
see what your conversations would be
once you all reached the merge so when
once you all merged and you met up with
drea and lindsey what was the
conversation about how you were going to
use that advantage yeah
that conversation was interesting
because if we want to rewind to that
moment when we all accepted the amulet
you guys didn't see it but dre and i
were like immediately like yes let's get
the amulet and lindsey was like i don't
know guys like this is like the you know
historically never gone well and we
really had to convince her to get it so
immediately i was like okay if anyone's
going to be unsure about this alliance
it's going to be lindsey so i was like
nervous to approach her but drea and i
immediately were very close as soon as
merge game we're like very similar
players we come from very similar
backgrounds i was like i'm going to play
with drea so when we approached lindsay
i was like this conversation could go
one of two ways
we could leave and not trust each other
and target each other or if we were
smart we don't want to leave any
opportunities on the table this could
bond us and allow us to work together
and fortunately for me it was the latter
and that really allowed us to create
this like majority eight even though i
will give credit more to omar than to
lindsay for creating the eight because
it was drea myself and omar that got
together and said let's work together
like me and the canadians and let's
create this majority so really that's
organically how that alliance happened
was thanks to the amulet
okay so the the advantages do do bring
something into the social part of the
game and i think it's a good call to
want to work with canadians but maybe i
am biased
so it's because i love that you're
giving us so many so much more insight
into the game so is there a part of your
game that you wish made air
no i will say
as a fan
as someone who like came to play
aggressively and did i'm really grateful
for the edit always kind of showing like
my thought process right because
even though i i went out eighth i feel
as though i was instrumental to a lot of
strategy and i was a huge obstacle for
people so it's nice to
to feel as though like because i played
aggressively
they were able to tell the story you
know like
so
i'm just grateful for the opportunity to
like showcase
my skills does that make sense
and
i like and that comes with good and bad
right i think at first like people
rooted for me because i was underdog and
eventually when i was in a position of
power they're like oh we hate this guy
because he's like cocky and arrogant and
it's like
and that comes with the edit and i
embraced it and i had fun with it and i
hope the audience did too
i think that there's no doubt that you
were a force in the game you were there
to play you had a lot of influence over
a lot of the votes and now that we're in
the phase where you're going to
transition you're going to become a jury
member
as a jury member what are you looking
for when it comes to voting for the
winner of the season
i'm looking for someone who understood
their game play
understood their strategy and is able to
articulate that at final tribal i need
the winner to eloquently explain their
moves and to own up to their gameplay
right like if you
if you say one thing explain and don't
just use words show through action what
you did
got it got it okay well of course we
started the conversation with your skin
so i have to circle back
can you explain what happened with the
bruise on your face
the bruise was the alternate for the
season that got uh removed
um no so i got hit with the boulder
during the challenge and it just like
bruised and i didn't know the bruise was
there that entire time until like we had
won a knife during the reward and i'm
like looking at it like it's a mirror
because i'm like very narcissistic and i
like notice the bruise
and i'm like picking at it because i'm
like go away and it came off so the
bruise was from the boulder it
disappeared because i literally picked
it off and then immediately oh my god i
told my durham friend as soon as i got
home she's like you should not have
picked that off because now you're like
more susceptible to like skin cancer and
i'm like oh no skin tip
i've learned so much about science just
now thank you hi wow you opened my eyes
mind blown sunscreen
100
if you can take anything from this high
interview it is sunscreen
i guess but hi you've given us so much
insight into your game today you've
given me great skincare tips so i want
to say thank you so much for chatting
today and truly wishing you all the best
thank you erica i appreciate it